did there come a time when you've met
directly with Ms hurt yes I did so in
conducting my evaluation I met with Miss
heard on two separate dates December
10th and December 17
2021. uh approximately how much time
you've spent with Miss heard
so the evaluation we spent 12 hours
directly with one another however there
were more there were more hours involved
in the evaluation with some breaks so we
spent seven hours together on the first
day there was as a result of the work
that you performed did you form any
opinions with respect to Ms heard I did
what were those opinions
I uh the results of misheard's
evaluation supported two diagnoses
borderline personality disorder and
histrionic personality disorder are you
aware that Mr Depp is on an audio
recording years earlier taunting Amber
Heard that she has a borderline
personality disorder I was made aware of
that in this case yes so you were
actually into the audience not
necessarily It's haunting but I do
recall hearing that Mr Depp had used
that phrase would you agree that a
disproportionate number of women are
tagged with a diagnosis of borderline
personality disorder
no that's not quite right
75 percent
the way you phrase it is not quite right
tell me tell me what's right okay so
there are more women who have been
diagnosed with bipolar disorder than men
it's more prevalent in women
trauma can cause borderline personality
disorders can't it no never
right now we know that there are people
who have borderline personality disorder
who have sustained childhood trauma
there are also people who have
borderline personality disorder who have
had no childhood trauma so like most
personality disorders and really like
most mental health issues in general
there seems to be both a biological
component in this case with borderline
personality disorder the research tends
to support a genetic component and
possibly a neurological component and
then there is also possibly an
environmental component triggering those
genetic markers would you agree that
if you did not find something that would
be in favor of Mr Depp and a negative to
Ms heard that you wouldn't be an expert
in this case
essentially into court if you're going
to say that Ms hurt is right Mr Depp is
wrong so as a forensic psychologist my
obligation is to the court is to the
fact finder I present science regardless
of what that science may be now when I
take a case my retainer agreement is
explicit about that